[Musique]
les amis j'ai un truc à vous dire ne
prêtez pas vos vêtements vos vêtements
ne leur était pas l es gens vous êtes
trop culotté avec les vêtements des
hautois compte achète un vêtement ne
peut pas vous non tu agis avec mon
vêtement comme si c'était tout vêtement
nombreux pas c'est pas ton vêtements
c'est mon vêtement c'est une affaire de
pros non mon matata n'en prennent pas
t'as pas tu met pas ses visées ses
visées prennent pas des vêtements les
jeunes font pas attention ne prend pas
tes vêtements prépare prêtera prennent
pas
ivy
les bb bb b b b est ce que je t'ai déjà
dit que tu sais cuisiner
alors pour être
celui là oui
chocolat amandes c'est super ok bah
écoute on va l'acheter
ramener à la maison comme ça tu vas
pouvoir le prendre pour moi et
j'ai su ce qui se passe car semble
vraiment vraiment des ressemble beaucoup
à ma fille à part le fait qu'ils états y
est sic
niamey
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous
[Musique]
là